breaking news
in breaking news situations or in crisis
zones viral photos circulate quickly
online but on social media it's common
for fake photos to circulate either
images that show something different
from what it's supposed to be portraying
or even photos that are manipulated the
question is how can you know whether the
photos you encounter are real or fake in
this video i'm going to show you four
useful tools to help you verify the
images you encounter online let's start
with this example
this photo allegedly shows a little girl
named malak who was supposedly killed by
an israeli airstrike in the gaza strip
in 2021 we found this claim on several
social networks and in numerous
languages
a good way to find out if the photo
really shows what it's said to show is
by doing a reverse image search my
colleague rachel bake breaks down how it
works
first of all i would upload the image to
a reverse image search tool like tinai
there i can find out when the image was
used for the first time and where
an important side note it's worth trying
out the reverse image search on other
platforms as well such as the russian
search engine yandex or google usually
different platforms offer different
results regarding our example rachel
found out
the picture is not from gaza and it's
also not current it actually shows a
young girl from russia called sophie and
she's alive and celebrating her sixth
birthday according to photos her mother
has uploaded on instagram
[Music]
so
the reverse image search is a really
useful tool nevertheless it's not always
helpful as our next example shows
sometimes the platforms don't have any
matches for the photo you're looking for
or sometimes you need a second way to
verify an image let's have a look at
another example
this photo was shared several times and
also used by mass media it allegedly
shows hordes of ukrainians fleeing from
the russian invasion at the main stage
in harkief at the beginning of march
2022 but many social media's users doubt
the photo is real
the reverse image search shows that the
picture really was posted at the
beginning of march but how can we be
sure that the photo is real and current
the first possible way to verify that is
to check whether the photo really shows
the train station hard keef for that we
can simply use a web-based mapping
platform such as google maps the
research shows that the photo really
does show the train station harjit
pasarjirsky you can recognize that by
comparing the yellow building or the
same display boards in both pictures
okay so the location is correct but how
can we confirm the photo was uploaded
for the first time at the beginning of
march let's take a closer look here you
can see a person holding an umbrella
like this one
many others are wearing a hood
so it seems as if it rained on the day
the photo was taken so now we have to
find out whether it rained in haruki at
the beginning of march or not we can
verify that with a really cool tool
using websites like wall from alpha you
can find out what the weather was like
on a certain day in a certain place
we found out that on the 4th and 5th of
march there was actually rainfall in
harkeef
[Music]
exciting the internet has a treasure
trove of resources and tools for
verification there are also a set of
tools that can help you tell where the
photos have been manipulated the one i
show you today is called forensically so
now let's take a closer look at this
photo does the surfer really swim
towards the waterfall
i upload the photon forensically try
several tools and in fact the forensic
analysis shows disturbances and thus
offers strong evidence that the image
has been manipulated forensically makes
changes to the image fire visible which
is particularly evident here in the
surface sail the server was therefore
very likely inserted into the photo of
the waterfall with photoshop or another
photo editing platform
[Music]
so now you know four basic tools for
helping to spot manipulated or fake
images the reverse image search online
mapping services weather data and the
quick forensic picture analysis
have you recently come across possible
fake images or videos then feel free to
write to us at factchecking dw.com